when we are studying microorganisms in a  laboratory we grow them in a broth we  give them a broth to nourish them you  call that a culture a culture medium  and if the organisms in this culture and  medium this cultural broth we're dying  off in great numbers or not thriving or  or or ill we would call that a toxic  culture in a society like ours more and  more people are getting sick more  addicted more mentally ill more people  are dying of overdoses that's also  representative of a toxic culture this  culture is not a not one that supports  healthy human growth but there's such a  wide gap between  that understanding and the practice of  medicine or how we treat people oh yeah  there's a huge um what we can call the  science and practice Gap  so the problem is not with the science  the problem is that we don't put the  science into practice